tempête politique autour d'un nouveau
plan de licenciement massif y est ouvert
à dijon ce groupe américain veut
regrouper toutes ses activités en écosse
le commerce extérieur français terminent
l'année sur 20 record plus de 30
milliards d'excédents alors que l'an
dernier on avait enregistré un déficit
du même ordre
les conflits dans l'ex yougoslavie le
groupement français envoie le porte
avions clemenceau dans l'adriatique à
nancy un grand spécialiste de la greffe
du rein condamné à cent mille francs
d'amendé pour avoir exigé des dessous de
table de certains de ses clients
les pavés de paris-roubaix bientôt
classé monument historique
madame monsieur bonsoir je vous propose
de commencer ce journal avec une bonne
nouvelle les feuilles d'impôts vont
bientôt se ramasser à la pelle
les formulaires de déclaration de
revenus sont vous voyez de couleur bleue
cette année et vous avez jusqu'au 12
mars minuit pour tout avouer au fisc
deux innovations cette année une
réduction d'impôt pour frais de
scolarisation d'enfants à charge et pour
frais d'emploi d'un salarié à domicile
précisions avec elisabetta ce n'est une
nombreuse progéniture ça coûte cher mais
fiscalement ça commence à rapporter gros
première nouveauté si vous employez à
votre domicile une personne pour garder
vos enfants quel que soit leur âge
vous allez bénéficier pour 1992 d'une
réduction d'impôt égale à la moitié du
salaire versé à cette personne mais
attention pour le calcul ce salaire est
plafonné à 25 mille francs pour l'année
exemple même si vous lui avez versé 40
mille francs
vous ne pourrez déduire au maximum que
douze mille cinq cents francs même chose
pour tous les types d'emplois à domicile
aide aux personnes âgées par exemple ou
femme de ménage
deuxième nouveauté encore une réduction
d'impôt cette fois si vous avez des
enfants à charge scolarisés ou étudiants
voici les tarifs moins 400 francs pour
un collégien moins 1000 francs pour un
lycéen -12 cents francs pour un étudiant
pour le reste vous retrouverez avec
plaisir vos rubriques habituelles rentes
viagères à titre onéreux revenus des
valeurs ou encore revenu différé à
imposer selon le système du quotient
le fabricant électroménager hoover a
annoncé hier la fermeture de son usine
de dijon où sont fabriqués
principalement des aspirateurs
une décision qui va entraîner la
suppression de plus de 600 emplois en
revanche ouvert va créer 400 emplois en
écosse où devraient être regroupées les
usines de cette filiale d'un groupe
américain une décision qui a provoqué
une tempête politique pierre bérégovoy
envisage de porter plainte contre les
autorités de bruxelles alors que le
socialiste jean auroux demande purement
et simplement le boycott des produits
hoover sur place et salariés ont
déclenché une grève
reportage pascal golomer jacques gérard
cette grille pierre ramaye est l'un des
premiers à l'avoir ouverte il y a
maintenant presque 30 ans 30 ans de bons
et loyaux services chez hoover pour
apprendre hier matin la fermeture de l
usine d'ici un an
plus de 600 suppressions d'emplois au
total alors depuis il fait grève
comme tout le personnel même s'il est
déjà presque résignée
on avait quand même l'espoir on a connu
quand même beaucoup de crise au sein de
la société à chaque fois on s'est remis
de ses crises mais l'a finalement on a
vraiment été tenu à l'écart de toutes
les informations et on ne fait que nous
annoncer maintenant la fermeture et de
lusine brève échéance des salariés
abassourdi écoeuré même si la rumeur
courait depuis quelques semaines hoover
vendait de plus en plus mal ces
aspirateurs il fallait fermer l'un des
sites de production entre dijon et caen
bus langue en écosse le groupe américain
a donc tranché il a obtenu des écossais
des réductions de salaires des heures
supplémentaires non payées une
limitation du droit de grève et le
versement d'une partie de leurs fonds de
retraite et en échange ils leur offrent
la production fait en bourgogne et 400
créations de postes un véritable
chantage à l'emploi
nous on s'est battu pendant longtemps
avec les politiques pour monter un
dossier financier on se rend compte que
ça servi à rien on s'est foutu de nous
la puce est quand même
c'est quand même anormal que l' on
déboise un coin sais pas si on peut dire
pour un boisé de côtes en photo avec
l'europe si c'est ça l'europe chapeau 1
hoover usine fantôme avant l'heure pas
question pour les salariés de rejoindre
dès demain les ateliers leur seule
revendication à présent c'est un plan
social correct avec un minimum de
licenciements
pour le reste la partie est déjà perdue
l'adversaire n'avais pas d'états d'âme
alors que la situation de l'emploi
continue on le voit se dégrader seules
bonnes nouvelles sur le front économique
l'excédent commercial de la france plus
de 30 milliards de francs l'an dernier
un record en quelque sorte depuis 78 léo
lamberton il doit faire des envieux
parmi ses collègues du gouvernement
dominique strauss kahn le ministre du
commerce extérieur et de l'industrie a
fait sensation ce matin 30 milliards de
francs d'excédent 92 pour notre balance
commerciale
personne n'espérait autant un niveau
historique qui tranche après des années
de déficits continus et qui permettent à
notre économie d'éviter la panne sèche
une des clés du succès c'est un
changement de stratégie beaucoup moins
de grands contrats au coup par coup en
afrique en amérique latine désormais les
entreprises cherchent des échanges plus
réguliers et sur des marchés solvables
cible de choix en 92 l'europe notamment
l'espagne l'italie et le royaume uni
c'est surtout dans l'industrie que les
français ont été forts notamment pour
les biens d'équipement professionnels
les ventes de matériel électrique et
aéronautiques ont décollé l'an dernier
l'agroalimentaire reprend du poil de la
bête après une année 91 mossad
l'excédent frôle 50 milliards de francs
grâce à la viande et aux produits
laitiers
en fait la facture énergétique qui en
général pèsent lourdement sur nos
comptes diminuent grâce à la baisse du
prix du baril de pétrole et du dollar
condition sinequanone d'une relance qui
tarde à venir et d'une halle était
efficace contre le chômage la baisse des
taux d'intérêt les choses étant ce
qu'elles sont nous sommes dépendants
d'une éventuelle baisse des taux
d'intérêt outre rhin le problème c'est
que les allemands ne veulent absolument
pas se serrer la ceinture pour financer
le développement de l'ex rda comme va
nous l'expliqué notre correspondant
permanent à berlin pascal digne et la
mine des mauvais jours car cela pourrait
aller mieux pour helmut kohl
son pacte de solidarité bas de l offre
du gouvernement fédéral aux régions au
patronat aux syndicats relancer la
machine à l'est moyens suggérés
économiser recours aux bonnes vieilles
recettes hausse des impôts et baisse des
allocations sociales bref une vraie cure
d'austérité
petit problème le chancelier
pratiquement le seul en allemagne à ne
pas trouver la pilule trop amère refus
des régions qui n'ont pas envie de
tailler dans leur budget refus de
l'opposition qui préfère ne pas porter
la co responsabilité d'une rigueur
évidemment à populaire refuse surtout
des syndicats pour qui ce sont les
salariés et le seul qui vont encore
devoir se sacrifier des syndicats
négociant par ailleurs de sérieuses
augmentations de salaires alors que la
croissance stagne on voit mal dans ces
conditions la bundesbank faire le geste
que la france attend c'est à dire
baisser les taux d'intérêt une
bundesbank qui n'a qu'un chiffre en tête
celui de l'inflation presque 4% l'an
passé avec ce pacte de solidarité
pratiquement mort nés ces salaires qui
risque une fois de plus de déraper
l'inflation 93 s'annonce élevée pas de
quoi remonter le moral des marchés
financiers en fait tout se passe comme
si l'allemagne prospère ne voulait
toujours pas se serrer la ceinture au
profit des parents pauvres de l'est
depuis des semaines donc le couple
franco allemand joue en quelque sorte à
soran le malheur dr ça siffle c'est que
l'on ne voit rien venir
non on peut tout à fait se re année au
premier ce maillot faire confiance au
premier semestre que 93 de cette année
la croissance en france serait nulle et
un risque de récession n'est pas à
écarter
même avec une petite reprise au second
semestre la france ne peut guère espérer
mieux que 0 5 à 1% de croissance
seulement cette année c'est ce que
disent les experts du ministère des
finances qui sont encore plus
pessimistes qu'en décembre
ces nouvelles prévisions n'ont pas
encore été rendus officiels mais les
experts soulignent que la situation
allemande devient très préoccupante
l'allemagne est maintenant dans le rouge
c'est à dire qu'elle est entrée dans la
4e récession depuis la fin de la guerre
la france subit donc les effets
conjugués des taux d'intérêt élevés et
de cette récession
comme notre déficit budgétaire des
rapports en même temps comme en faillite
et chômage est bien notre situation est
de plus en plus inconfortable malgré les
bons chiffres qu'on vient de voir du
commerce extérieur
merci la guerre civile maintenant dans
l'ex yougoslavie la france a emboîté le
pas la grande bretagne en décidant à son
tour d'envoyer dans l'adriatique le
porte avions clemenceau une flottille de
six navires d'accompagnement capable
d'effectuer selon les besoins des
opérations offensives ou des actions
d'évacuation se porte avion quittera
toulon probablement jeudi
reportage sur place anne mourgues
jean-françois giorgetti le porte avions
clemenceau a regagné précipitamment son
port d'attache ce matin en rade de
toulon à bord préparatifs de départ on
s'affaire à compléter le matériel faire
le plein de carburant de vivres de
munitions appareillage prévue au plus
tard vendredi matin le clemenceau sera
accompagné de huit autres navires dont
deux de lutte anti aériennes et de lutte
anti sous marine
une fois en mer il sera rejoint par une
quarantaine d'avions et d'hélicoptères
arrivées probables au large des côtes
croates en fin de semaine le clemenceau
prendre à leur place aux côtés des porte
avions américains et britanniques
sa mission assurer la protection des
casques bleus
éventuellement intervenir en cas de
nécessité selon pierre joxe toujours
dans le cadre des résolutions des
nations unies
une protection renforcée juger par le
ministre de la défense indispensable au
lendemain de la mort en croatie de deux
casques bleus français
précisément après ce drame dans le sud
de la croatie françois mitterrand a
fermement demandé à son homologue croate
d'assurer la sécurité des casques bleus
français déployés dans son pays selon
les observateurs de l'onu sur place les
forces croates ont poursuivi aujourd'hui
leur offensive contre l'enclavé serbe de
la krajina
malgré la résolution du conseil de
sécurité demandant leur retrait olivier
dernière le qg des casques bleus
français près de masse l'inique en
krajina il n'est plus opérationnel à
partir d'aujourd'hui les soldats
français s'installeront ailleurs dans
une zone à moindre risque décision prise
aujourd'hui par l'état major
les raisons de cette décision les
soldats français sauront mieux protéger
à l'avenir par un renfort d'artillerie
qui arrivera dans les prochains jours
d'autre part la répartition des
effectifs autant croatie qu'en bosnie
multiplie les risques alors ils seront
regroupés autant que faire se peut enfin
la présence des avions de combat et des
hélicoptères du clemenceau à seront
peut-être une dissuasion très attendu
par ses soldats de la paix qui se
sentent pour l'instant isolé au milieu
des combats dont ils sont trop souvent
les cibles 11 casques bleus français
tués et 80 blessés dont 20 sont dans un
état grave
depuis leur déploiement sur le terrain
autour du pont de masse lenica ou plutôt
de ce qu'il en reste c'est relativement
calme mais ce soir l'armée croate
bombardent à l'armé lourde la zone de
zadar avec des casques bleus qui risque
à nouveau d'être pris entre deux feux
des croates apparemment déterminés et
qui exerce à leur tour une sorte de
chantage le président croate franjo
tudjman déclare que son armée ne bougera
pas tant que les serbes ne rompt pas
restitué leur armement lourd subtilisé
aux forces de la paix de l'onu à new
york le conseil de sécurité a condamné
cette nouvelle offensive croates et les
serbes n'ont pas caché leur satisfaction
ils sont passés en l'espace de quelques
jours du statut d'agresseur au statut
d'agresser et peuvent annoncer sans
crainte ce soir que les serbes de bosnie
vont prêter main forte aux serbes de
krajina
le continent africain déchiré par toute
une série de conflits politico ethniques
au rwanda au moins 53 morts à la suite
d'affrontements entre tribus rivales en
casamance au sud du sénégal sept jeunes
gens membres de la croix rouge locale
ont été tuées à la suite de l'explosion
de leur voiture sur une mine et à lomé
la capitale du togo
la situation est toujours
particulièrement tendue hier une
manifestation de l'opposition a été
réprimée par la police qui a tiré
dernier bilan au moins 16 morts et plus
de 40 blessés gérard vos fils jean qui
est à terre sans autorisation en dépit
de ces rappels à l'ordre le président
eyadema n'a pas été entendu par les
militaires depuis deux ans le cycle
manifestation violente répression se
perpétue au togo hier la police et
l'armée ont encore tiré sur la foule à
l'issue d'une manifestation pacifique
organisé par l'opposition
il y avait sur place des témoins
privilégiés en mission bons offices
marcel debarge et son homologue allemand
nous avons adressé une mise en garde
sévère au gouvernement togolais sur la
nécessité de situer les responsabilités
en proposant notamment une commission ou
un groupe international pour savoir ce
qui s'était passé réellement
on ne peut pas avoir le discours de la
politesse grandiose et en même temps
avoir de telles pratiques
le ministère des affaires étrangères
déplore ces graves événements la
communauté économique européenne
elle a déjà décidé de suspendre de facto
toute coopération avec le togo
le secrétaire général de l'onu commence
à perdre patience boutros boutros ghali
a recommandé au conseil de sécurité de
prendre je cite toute mesure nécessaire
pour obliger israël à autoriser le
retour des quelque 400 palestiniens
expulsés en décembre dernier vers le sud
liban pourrait-on imaginer en france
danielle mitterrand ou anne aymone
giscard d'estaing chargé tout à fait
officiellement de coordonner la réforme
de la sécurité sociale
c'est toutes proportions gardées bien
sûr ce qui se passe actuellement aux
etats-unis bill clinton le nouveau
président a en effet chargé son épouse
kilari de présider un groupe d'experts
chargé d'élaborer un projet de réforme
du système de santé à washington pour
france 2 jean marc il use je ne suis pas
le genre à rester à la maison et faire
des petits gâteaux en plein coeur de la
campagne quand elle défend bec et ongles
son candidat de marie ses propos
d'hillary clinton avait provoqué une
levée de boucliers et pour calmer la
fureur des mères de famille et des
conservateurs
hilary machine arrière toute s'était
contenté quelque temps de jouer les
femmes effacées
lors des visites du lean élections
obligent mais aujourd'hui pourtant plus
personne ne s'étonne de voir hillary
rodham clinton
elle tient rodham son nom de jeune fille
murmurait publiquement ses conseils au
président des états unis
son rôle ne se limitera donc pas à jouer
les épouses de charb où les dames
patronnesses considérée comme l'une des
meilleurs juristes des états unis elle a
toujours gagné plus que son mari mais
son nouveau job sera bénévole
hier le président des états unis l'a
chargé de coordonner la réflexion de six
ministres sur le casse tête politique
numéro un de la présidence clinton
la réforme du système de santé et outre
ces appartements de première dame
hillary clinton aura aussi son bureau
dans la lhouest
de la maison blanche juste au dessus de
celui du président qu'on se le dise les
angels
le président des états unis est monsieur
clinton si ce genre d'astuce ne fait
déjà plus les délices du tout washington
c'est parce que hilary n'est désormais
plus seulement la première dame des
etats unis elle est un pouvoir avec
laquelle washington devra compter à
prague l'ancien écrivain vaclav havel
vient d'être élu président de la
république tchèque qui ne nouvelle
république issue au 1er janvier de la
partition de l'ex tchécoslovaquie
des chercheurs britanniques viennent de
mettre au point un vaccin expérimental
contre le virus d'epstein barr virus à
l'origine de la mononucléose infectieuse
baptisé par nos grands mères maladie
défiance est parce qu il s'attrape et en
s'embrassant ce virus fait des ravages
dans certains pays en voie de
développement car il s'accompagne
souvent d'un cancer à londres pour
france 2 christian marie monnet trois
équipes de chercheurs britanniques à
manchester bristol et birmingham ont mis
au point un vaccin qui pourrait prévenir
certains cancers d'origine virale soit
20% des cancers c'est à dire cinq
millions de malades dans le monde
après 25 ans de recherche ils sont
convaincus qu'il sera efficace contre le
virus d'epstein barr responsable de
plusieurs cancers sulle de la mâchoire
fosses nasales également peut provoquer
certaines mononucléose il espère pouvoir
adapter le vaccin à la maladie d'hodgkin
ce qui atteint le système lymphatique
les premiers tests commenceront d'ici la
fin de l'année sur une trentaine de
volontaires
nous espérons pouvoir venir en aide à
six malades mais tant qu'on n'a pas
essayé le vaccin on ne peut rien dire
les chercheurs sont convaincus que les
méthodes de prévention passe par les
vaccins antiviraux
ils ont d'ailleurs d'autres projets nous
essaierons le vaccin qui sera alors le
deuxième essai contre le virus de
papillons qui est liée au cancer de
l'utérus chez les femmes
une nouvelle bien accueillie par toute
la presse britannique
et pour cette femme atteinte d'une
tumeur au cerveau une raison d'espérer
la plupart des gens qui se sentent
fatigués impute cette faiblesse à un
manque de fer dans l'organisme
or paradoxe le faire et parfois trop
présent dans l'organisme
cette anomalie génétique appelée
hémochromatose tous plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de français qui parfois
l'ignorent or cette maladie est tout à
fait curable à condition d'être soigné à
temps
reportage jean daniel flaysakier michel
levasseur dans sa vie professionnelle de
plombier gabriel aubry est selon su
maîtriser les métaux
depuis sa retraite il s'est aperçu qu'il
avait un problème personnel avec le
faire affaires qui s'accumulent
anormalement de son organisme
monsieur le beurrier souffre en effet
d'hémochromatose la plus fréquente des
maladies génétiques
elle concerne au moins cinquante mille
français est le signe principal de cette
maladie c'est une fatigue persistante
dans ma vie j'étais très fatigué et
toujours fatigués
en plus j'avais des douleurs partout
vous allez dans les pieds dans les allés
prier ici surtout là où ça durait depuis
longtemps ça fait et puis voilà je
l'avais à tanger des douleurs le
paradoxe c'est que cette maladie
méconnue alors que son diagnostic est
simple à faire il suffit d'une prise de
sang et du dosage notamment du taux de
fer le traitement peut paraître encore
plus surprenant à une époque de haute
sophistication puisqu'il s'agit de faire
ni plus ni moins qu'une saignée mais pas
la saignée de molière une saignée fait
par une infirmière qui va permettre de
retirer un tout petit peu moins d'un
demi litre de sang un sens qu'on va
jeter immédiatement
il s'agit chez les patients de les
soumettre des soustractions sanguine
hebdomadaire pendant des mois jusqu'à ce
que la totalité du faire un excès de
l'organisme soit éliminé ça veut dire
qu'on peut parler de guérison complète
ça veut dire que sous réserve que le
diagnostic était posée suffisamment tôt
c'est le point crucial
on peut effectivement chez les patientes
parler de guérison mais les médecins
veulent aussi voir les parents les
frères les soeurs et les enfants des
personnes atteintes d'hémochromatose
pour vérifier ses n'ont pas elles aussi
des dépôts anormaux de faire dans leur
foi comme ici c'est rentable au plan du
diagnostic c'est rentable au plan de
l'efficacité au plan du diagnostic sur
l'ensemble des sujets qui appartenaient
à des familles d'hémochromatose bien sûr
que nous
provoqué l'an dernier et bien sûr 400
personnes nous avons abouti à 50
diagnostic démocrate au la maladie ne
requiert aucun régime particulier seule
interdiction absolue l'alcool y compris
bière vin et cidre
attention aussi aux produits du commerce
enrichir difficilement en faire et
vitamine c mais la bonne nouvelle c'est
que les épinards leur est permis le
tribunal correctionnel de nancy a
condamné aujourd'hui à 100 mille francs
d'amendé le professeur jacques lhermitte
reconnu coupable d'extorsion de fonds
spécialiste réputé de la greffe du rein
cet urologue a été reconnu coupable
d'avoir extorqué près de trente mille
francs à 11 de ses patients avant
opération en forme de dessous de table
reportage christine boss un grand absent
ce matin au tribunal de nancy
le professeur lhermitte lui même qui
n'avait apparemment pas jugé utile de se
rendre à l'énoncé de son jugement peut
être craignait-il les deux ans de prison
avec sursis assortie de 150 mille francs
d'amendé requis par le procureur général
en fait reconnu coupable d'extorsion de
fonds à l'égard de lons de ses patients
l'urologue nancéen n'est condamné qu'à
cent mille francs d'amendé soit à peu
près l'équivalent de son salaire mensuel
une peine clémente mais une condamnation
tout de même c'est une peine qui n'est
pas sévère mais comme je le répète et ça
je me tiens cette position sur le
principe de la condamnation qui compte
avant tout dans ce type d'affaires tu
les as tous même sans aller jusqu'à dire
justice à deux vitesses il est vrai que
la justice ne peut être pas la même pour
tout le monde
pour monsieur lhermitte une condamnation
quelle qu'elle soit et est grave c'est
vrai qu' il n'y a qu'une sanction
d'amande je le répète mais c'est une
sanction tout de même est dans sa
situation c'est très très embarrassant
pour ne pas dire plus
enfin cette peine ne sera pas inscrite
au casier judiciaire du condamné
il pourra donc continuer à exercer à
moins que le conseil national de l'ordre
des médecins de le sanctionne après
avoir été condamné par la justice
il va être à présent jugé par ses pairs
qui pourront à leur tour sanctionner ou
non ces pratiques de dessous de table si
tout va comme sur des roulettes ou
plutôt des roues de train le tunnel sous
la manche ce devrait être ouvert au
trafic ferroviaire à la fin de cette
année la sncf et son homologue
britannique sont si j'ose dire sur la
même voie pour assurer ce service
la british airways a engagé un vaste
programme de
passion pour ces conducteurs afin de les
familiariser avec la signalisation
française eurostar le nouveau train
paris-londres
pour les britanniques la france est au
bout du rail avec l'ouverture prochaine
du tunnel sous la manche
les chemins de fer britanniques s'y
prépare sérieusement il forme une
centaine de conducteurs qui apprennent
les signaux avec le simulateur français
se familiarise avec la vitesse qui sera
de 300 km/heure en france contre
seulement 160 en grande bretagne ce ne
sera pas la principale difficulté même
si les trains roulent à gauche en france
comme en grande-bretagne avant s'il ya
une morale charrie un 1,7
vous avez compris quelle sera leur vrai
problème c'est la non parce que si on
est un con docteur en breton en beauté
c'est le même
ainsi si vous êtes en vous et en france
et en belgique
c'est le savoir faire c'est là même les
apprennent et scrupuleusement le
français ferroviaire mais on a hâte de
découvrir le vrai pari dont celui du
simulateur
nous avons quitté londres et les moins
de trois heures et nous arrivons à paris
grâce au tunnel sous la manche l'europe
du rail est sur la bonne voie et les
voyageurs vont pouvoir en faire
l'expérience d'ici la fin de l'année et
découvrir quelle europe sans mère et
sans frontières est une réalité dans
notre série on vit une époque formidable
cette innovation qui intéressera entre
autres les incultes paresseux de
surcroît la mise en vente par larousse
d'un dictionnaire électronique 57 mille
maux pour mille francs le bonheur des
amateurs de scrabble comme patrick
estève et oui bruno on peut en écrire
des mots différents avec les 26 lettres
de l'alphabet le petit larousse en
recense déjà 58 1700 et c'est bien
agréable de pouvoir voyager à travers
ses mots seulement il n'y a pas 36
solutions pour avoir le dictionnaire
sous la main qu'il n'y en a même que
trois
la première un peu fatiguant
physiquement vous en conviendrez c'est
de transporter en permanence avec soi
et puis trouver une définition reste un
peu fastidieux exemple p o u pouzzolane
nom féminin roches volcaniques à
structure alvéolaire etc etc
deuxième solution vous apprenez par
coeur tout le dictionnaire pouzzolane
nom féminin rejoint le kamikaze
structure alvéolaire recherché en
construction pour ses qualités
d'isolation thermique et phonique
bon c'est un peu éprouvant sur le plan
cérébral je vous la corde
troisième solution vous sortez le dico
de votre poche et vous cherchez votre
mot avantage même si vous faites des
fautes d'orthographe
la machine vous retrouve le bon mot
atmosphère et voilà mais c'est bien
connu dans les définitions on vous
renvoie immanquablement à d'autres mots
cette fois il suffit de souligner ce mot
est la machine vous communique
instantanément la nouvelle définition
vous pouvez également effectuer la
recherche de manière thématique
l'ordinateur possède 60 thèmes
différents
vous pouvez aussi devenir grâce à lui
instantanément un super champion des
mots croisés un mot de cinq lettres
commençant par paix et finissant par au
facile par et au patio piano polio porno
porte aux primo philo photo mais il faut
quand même que je vous prévienne pour
990 francs
la rousse électronique ne sait pas tout
faire il ne connaît pas les noms propres
rien par exemple au nom de bruno masure
il ne s'est pas encore servir de grille
pain ou servir le café voilà un autre
mot beaucoup plus sérieux attentats
tentative criminelle contre une personne
ou un bâtiment surtout dans un contexte
politique
les policiers niçois connaissent
désormais très bien cette définition
leur ville a en effet été secoué par
huit attentats depuis le début de cette
année attentat non revendiqué
le dernier cette nuit s'est produit à
200 mètres du commissariat central
reportage va les ermites entre 200 et
300 grammes des dynamites simplement
posé devant ce petit snack en plein
centre ville de nice il était 4h30 du
matin pas de victimes
si ce n'est une multitude de vitres qui
ont explosé le sup à racketter
je n'ai pas reçu de menaces ni de coups
de téléphone anonymes rire rien rires je
suis quand même mère de famille et je
travaille honnêtement je fais comme tout
le monde je fais mes amis font ce
travail honnêtement je ne comprends pas
il y une semaine cinq balles avait déjà
été tiré dans la vitrine du snack plus
graves début décembre à 8h du matin un
sac en plastique contenant de la
dynamite été trouvés devant le mas
un des côtés un local de jeux vidéo mais
la liste n'est pas close hier encore
dans un parking privé
trois grenades ont été découvertes à
temps puisque l'une d'entre elles
étaient des goûts plié en moins d'un
mois c'est le huitième attentat commis à
nice la multiplicité des cibles ne
facilite pas du tout la tâche des
enquêteurs qui ne privilégie toujours
office de particulière ses attentes à
rendre chèvre les policiers niçois dans
un petit village d'espagne ce sont les
défenseurs des animaux qui protestent
contre une pratique locale aussi stupide
que cruelle le lancer de chèvre depuis
le clocher de l'église
patrice from them on est restés bouche
bée quand ils en ont fini avec les
taureaux les espagnols s'occupe des
chèvres une fois l'an bic est balancé du
haut d'un clocher faisait les frais de
cette coutume ancestrale mais cette
année le village de manganèse et 500
âmes 3000 les jours de fête et le parec
c'en est une
innove ainsi dick est test les lois
élémentaires de l'attraction terrestre
avant de rebondir sur une toile
plastifiée le tout se passe sous les
hourras d'un troupeau de bipèdes dont on
ne sait qui de lui ou de la victime est
le plus cher revenant à bic est un
vétérinaire l'a ausculté elle est
indemne et pour cause en cas de bobo la
municipalité risquait une amende de 225
mille francs c'est marrant quand on
touche au porte monnaie
l'alibi de la tradition s'évapore alors
que bourges vient d'entrer dans le
patrimoine mondial je parle de la
cathédrale figurez vous qu'un autre
morceau de nos patrimoines va bientôt
être classé les sept kilomètres de pavés
de paris roubaix
reportage de notre envoyé spécial à
cysoing benoît gadret ils ont forgé la
légende du paris roubaix les chemins de
granit fait des bébés difformes
véritable piège pour les pauvres
c'est à lois de l'équilibré et c'est
toute la classe du coureur qui rentrent
en jeu et ça devient dangereux c'est les
glissades c'est les chutes mais c'est ce
qui fait le folklore de paris-roubaix
finalement messi ou xviiie siècle les
chemins pavés faisaient figure
d'autoroute
aujourd'hui ces voies chaotique attire
les foudres des riverains au charme
folklorique du pavé les communes
préfèrent le macadam et chaque année ce
sont des secteurs entiers qui
disparaissent gestion très inquiet car
si ce petit jeu continuer un jour serait
arrivé où nous n'aurions plus trouver
suffisamment de pavés pour organiser
paris roubaix alors pour sauver les
pavés et le pari rouvert le ministre de
l'environnement engagé aujourd'hui une
procédure de classement pour un premier
tronçon de 8 km je pense que c'est une
nouvelle conception du patrimoine
c'est un patrimoine populaire est
vivante et aujourd'hui ces pavés sont
classés ça veut dire qu'on ne peut plus
y toucher on ne peut plus les démolir on
ne peut plus les bétonné classer les
pavés la mesure est inédite mais il faut
dire qu'à la veille de fêter son
centenaire la reine des classiques fait
elle aussi figure de monument aux
internationaux de tennis d'australie
julie allard a frôlé l'exploit la nuit
dernière la troisième joueuse française
a failli éliminer monica seles numéro un
mondial en fait c'était cet après midi
mary pierce a également été éliminé en
quarts de finale de ce tournoi par
l'argentine gabriela sabatini
je signale aux passionnés de tennis que
france 2 retransmettra cette nuit à
partir d'une heure et quart en direct de
mails vont bien sûr le match de quart de
finale opposant guy forget à l'allemand
michael stich suite des présentations
des collections haute couture
printemps-été 93 avec cette constatation
les couturiers propriétaires de leur
entreprise souffre apparemment moins de
la crise que leurs concurrents exemple
emmanuel ungaro et filles venaient
reportage marie-josée le picard jean
louis molle un retour aux sources
le grand couturier philippe venet
présente chez lui dans les salon beige
pâle de la maison de couture et après
les pantalons pyjama universel favoris
de la saison
c'est ailleurs ses robes et manteaux
sont absolument cours coup absolument
cours trois quarts des clients sont
américaines mais pas question de cacher
ces gens donc l'égérie qu'on les tue
ils n'ont pas l'air d'être comme si vous
alliez fait nous mêmes le tissu qui
avait à bord de spi c'est bien à une ou
de couture où le sens du tissu joue sur
le corps c'est le vrai art du couturier
seul propriétaire de sa maison philippe
venet qui fait constamment à la navette
entre les états unis et paris ne se
plaint pas de la crise et la chose
d'horrible qui ont pu priver dernières
saisons et une fille en sixième
la mode est plus théâtral chez emmanuel
ungaro plus exubérante avec un
parti-pris vins primés et de motifs
graphiques en mélange qui sont l'une des
signatures les plus faciles à
reconnaître de ce grand couturier lui
aussi il est l'unique propriétaire de
son affaire lui aussi il affiche
beaucoup de confiance en l'avenir et en
sa clientèle apparemment les couturiers
les plus heureux ne sont pas ce qu'ils
sont devenus les salariés le groupe
financier mais ceux qui malgré les
difficultés et les responsabilités que
cela conforte sont restés maîtres à bord
voilà changeront steele à 20h 22h 45 et
que bas les masques l'émission de
mireille dumas consacré ce soir à
l'obésité
vers minuit le tout dernier journal en
compagnie de philippe lefait vers 1h15
donc en direct de melbourne le match
forget stitch
bonne fête aux paul les bonnes
anniversaire à stéphane grappelli 85 ans
paul newman 67 ans roger vadim 65 ans et
michel sardou 46 ans aujourd'hui dans un
instant la météo sophie davant retour de
la douceur par l'ouest
à demain matters bonsoir merci